iamsterdam
the knaus the wierde the bite more al mare
by chair
i think one of the busiest with
feature makes the most horrific damage
don't dare say yes there every line
and the zoology telegraph needs a week
my name is jan de Jonge i am
skipper at  waternet
i'm just fed and i'm also a
skipper
there go you chicks those five your needle
and instagram
cooling overview that grinds and along and
was an underground in new channel
work power or lost count
how many bikes they get out of each day
you on an annual basis it is
about the separation between 15 and 20
thousand preferably you drive again at passion
and i taste at ado canal inamsterdam
the clean water is the model i my
knowledge not function the council are also
for the cruise and especially there well yes  or
can more now it a cup
start typing above the water
and youtube can fp abs by wire so that
way bytes confused der finds on a
simple or invades north wind
i  think that the 80% is due to the
clubbing public there is
growing
the machine usp circuit and oversized
clutch in the choice between water and
diet coke my fire fire the edges and the
channel so yes how many times in him for
you so far gala about to grab the chocolate
and they have to be
taken there,
you are taken out, are eventually
recycled again, so
cola cans or beer cans are made of this again,
because
I think proof of the most
photographed and filmed masters
are in Amsterdam,
this is not, I think, he is in the world
where this work  whether this
work takes place
so this is unique
you can online in amsterdam
[Music]